it's been a little over a month since
eddie van halen's untimely death and you
know
to millions of fans he will always be a
rock legend but
nothing was more important to eddie than
being a dad
his son wolf gang meant everything to
him are you doing man
i'm terrible i'm trying to stay positive
but man it's
it's been the worst month of my life i
don't have a dad anymore and i have to
figure out how to process that and deal
with it
what was it like those last few months
and then those last few days
it was really rough it just seems like
he never got a break i was very happy i
was able to
spend every second with him that i could
with his band mammoth wvh wolfgang just
released the song
distance dedicated to his dad the video
filled with touching home movies
i cried every time it's it's it's very
hard to watch what did your mom think of
the video
all i had to do was walk into her house
and say hey i have the video and she
started crying
before she even watched it she's watched
it countless times she's actually
probably downstairs on the couch right
now watching it he is my baby i don't
care what he says
et's been with the family since wolfy
was a baby at 16
he begged his mom to go on tour with his
dad he really convinced me
that it was a good thing for him and it
really did end up being a good thing for
me
[Music]
every moment i shared on stage with my
dad was was a gift
and i'll treasure those forever one of
my favorite things he ever told me
that his father told him when you're
playing music if you ever make a mistake
do it twice so that way people think you
did it on purpose
there have been rumors that you may go
out and you may replace your dad in the
band
oh yeah no no way that'll never happen
you can't have
van halen without eddie van gaal
the video ends with that message from
your dad so proud of you i
love you so much he used to leave me
messages like that all the time and i
thought that one was a really
great way to cap the video off to really
show people how
loving of a father he was here's the
really beautiful thing
all the proceeds from that song will go
to the mr holland's opus foundation
which exposes underprivileged kids to
music and it's already number one on
itunes
i mean it just makes me happy that
result makes everyone happy yeah